[Music]
legends are not born there are a few
people who could truly claim to be
legends and even fewer who can live up
to the meaning of the word very close he
hit a button he's so genius the time
he's in a talk about a punk a Grand
Finals of evil Toki doe is perhaps the
most decorated fighting game player in
history with top eight placements in
over a dozen different games over his
career he is one of the greatest players
the fighting game community has ever
seen a focused Aikido is probably one of
the scariest people that you can
actually imagine if you're in a
competitive field and yet when you think
of fighting games specifically Street
Fighter Tokyo isn't the first person who
comes to mind and that kind of like
mentality changed to be known from like
plays the cheapest characters to just
wants to improve himself to be the best
is like that's a huge change in how he
is like a person not just the competitor
right Tokyo has spent most of his career
in Daigo shadow he's dedicated his life
to perfecting his craft all in his quest
to become something many believe he
already is I want to be President this
is his story
[Applause]
fighting game is something so great
[Music]
Hajime Tokyo Taniguchi was born on July
7th 1985 in Kanazawa Japan named by his
grandfather Hajime means both to begin
and first and some would argue that his
destiny was always to be number one but
it took him some time to get there
Tokyo wasn't much of a gamer early on
but after moving and switching schools
he found himself without many friends oh
I just have to pray myself so I just go
back oh damn
pray not only fighting game I pray
Street Fighter the first fighting game
he picked up with Street Fighter 2 which
he often played at home by himself
but twice a year he'd get to play
competitively while he visited his
cousin in Okinawa in school I don't have
friend battle in my mother's hometown
I have a friend cousin under his a very
good fighting game
TRAI so the I we play fighting game each
other and I didn't
winged taquitos cousin was older and
better at the fighting games they played
but by the time they were playing Virtua
Fighter 2 torpedo finally got the upper
hand I practiced a lot so I'm confident
so the Xavier later I challenged him
again then I beat him just a little bit
so at the time I am I did it beating his
cousin gave torpedo a taste of the rush
he spent the rest of his life chasing
and the concept of constant
self-improvement in pursuit of victory
became core to his identity the man we
now know as Tokyo has been going by that
name ever since middle school back then
he would play King of Fighters in
arcades and quickly became known for
using a cheesy tactic my senpai call me
oh you are very betrayer you just do
jump kick and the so fireball your name
is Toki door oh okay I accept it I'm
Toki though even though it may have
pissed off his friends Tokyo strategy
worked and became his approach to all
fighting games he played everything and
made sure to pick the true stuff
he/she just would pick whatever was the
most effective thing and win like in
super turbo when he played super driver
he just used Vega he just did the the
heel ball the wall dive tactics when we
played hyper Street Fighter 2 which is
the version that let you play every
single version of every character he
just played see II bison in that game he
didn't care so he just did whatever it
took to win he played the most you know
oppressive strategy possible and so you
know he was dirty taquito and it was
wonderful a few years later after
suffering a devastating loss
Tokyo heard a rumor about an American
fighting game tournament but there was
one problem he wasn't sure if his father
would let him travel to the United
States I asked my father because I don't
have money so I need parents money so I
asked father other time I
didn't sink my father let me join but my
father's said oh you want to go to us to
join some some video game tournament
okay I pay for you I'm very surprised
my father is for me it's very hard to
say he's the affiliate on the streak
taquito traveled with the Japanese
contingent and despite being just 17 got
his first taste at international success
taquito showed America how to properly
play EURion and third strike and
defeated fighting game legend Onuki
in Capcom vs. SNK 2 on the main stage it
was his first Evo victory and it
wouldn't be his last taquitos career
victory span an enormous number of games
over the years he's picked up top 8
placements in 14 different titles but
taquitos first Evo victory didn't kick
off his fighting game career so much as
it put it on pause at 17 Tokyo still had
a few years before University but after
coming home from Evo he started to apply
to Tokyo University one of the most
prestigious schools in Japan Tokyo still
played fighting games during his studies
and returned to Evo in 2005 2007 and
2008 even winning Super Street Fighter 2
turbo at Evo of 7 but back home
Tokyo focused on his studies I didn't
very fighting Gabe I study a lot
it wasn't the Tokyo didn't have time to
play fighting games it's that he loved
pursuing his studies at least he did
until it was time for his master's
degree I didn't go to a cage at the time
because of my study is very hard and it
was so fun
but my score for entrance examination
for Master degree is bad very bad then I
have to change I can
estou Kido grew tired of the academic
lifestyle a new opportunity presented
itself Street Fighter 4 released in
Japanese arcades in 2008 and by 2009 was
reviving the North American fgc on
consoles as well the players Tokyo had
competed with in high school were coming
back and when he dropped out of his
master's program in 2010 topito came
back to Tokyo was a few years late -
Street Fighter 4 but when he did show up
he wanted to make a splash and quickly
found himself drawn to street fighters
enigmatic villain picking a street
fighter main is often a practical choice
but for some players their chosen
character transcends tiers and serves as
a reflection of themselves
mechanically Akuma is a low health high
damage character that demands perfection
at the highest level narrative Lee he's
a character that's found ultimate power
and now seeks an opponent who can truly
challenge him in reality he and taquito
were a perfect match
you miserable when you pick a kuma
you're making a statement you're telling
your opponent that you can play
perfectly that you can destroy and
okeydoke lays a kuma for those very
reasons he demands perfection from his
character from his opponents and from
himself
it's character concept
he has roll house but he has everything
else that mean if I must have him he's a
best character for me but the road to
perfection is paved with defeat
something Tokyo knows all too well
[Music]
[Applause]
Tokyo found adapting to Street Fighter 4
difficult at first at first I don't
think he is good because I couldn't beat
anyone but
little by little all this character good
at least not bad they're all good all
this talk but he quickly found his
footing
[Music]
when it came to Street Fighter Tokyo was
too often the bridesmaid and never the
bride
he was a fixture in the top eight but
winning it all was a rare occurrence
Street Fighter 4 was defined by small
periods of dominance from a handful of
players but Tokyo never had the
consecutive major victories to establish
his dynasty there were incredible
victories to be sure you don't take that
but he had his slip-ups too and he was
just not even moving that fish
completely annihilated by the Beast Wow
they called actually there's actually
drowning about that and of course they
were the times he was so close to
tasting victory and felt just short
but while Tokyo was grinding out Street
Fighter 4 he was juggling more games
than any other top player Tokyo holds
titles in Soul Calibur critical edge
Tekken King of Fighters
if you'll take sit down there was too
much momentum going on there Street
Fighter cross Tekken and that's it
Aikido is gonna take it over it Jason
Dead or Alive
persona 4 arena that's gonna hurt that
might be the end of it and there it is
Tekken Tag Tournament CBS 2 and Marvel
vs. Capcom 3 and so Kido is your Marvel
vs. Capcom 3 grand champion of cgo 2011
not to mention his dozens of victories
in main series Street Fighter games and
that's it ladies and gentlemen great
games I actually really enjoyed watching
that yeah I gotta tell you it's been a
long time since I watched third strike
that was really nice Tokita was a multi
game athlete with a penchant for the
dramatic
he liked putting on a show for the fans
and quickly developed a reputation as
the murderface
so Kido gets up and walks off
[Applause]
the murderface nickname came from the
comically serious face he put on when he
sat down to play but the name eventually
came to be associated with his
incredible hilarious Popoff's
and he's up in front of the screen that
is unprecedented he's upped the ante and
Kay Brad's like that just happened
getting murderface is an incredible
thing o inspiring and unbelievably
tilting all at once but behind the
scenes taquito was struggling sure he
was having fun but he felt there was
something missing something he'd give up
his reputation to get taquito worked a
few part-time jobs to pay the bills
after University but he was all to
support the one thing he truly cared
about fighting games and after
dominating CEO Street Fighter and MVC
events in 2011 Toki toe is signed by Mad
Catz which led him solely focus on his
passion but the sponsorship meant more
than just going to tournaments he was
now on the same team as fighting game
legend Daigo Umehara it was proof that
Tokyo could stand shoulder-to-shoulder
with the greatest fighting game player
of all time Toki dough and Daigo had
clashed plenty of times before but
seeing them on the same team was
something special a head of Mad Catz
unveiled Japan in 2013 Daigo Tokyo were
practicing behind the scenes
Daigo was slated to face off against
infiltration then considered the best
player in the world and in order to beat
his Akuma Daigo needed to practice
against the best Akuma player he could
find and so he turned to Toki dough the
day before Moscow sunbathed
he asked me
okay let's let's practice then he did he
destroy me it was a most shocked
experience for me oh it's same human
kind but of his another level Daigo went
on to demolish infiltration in one of
the most one-sided first attend matches
either player had ever participated in
[Applause]
but Tokita was left wondering what the
point was sure he was a
jack-of-all-trades a veritable fighting
game savant who was good at any fighting
game he touched but even when the
pressure was off he couldn't beat the
best
he was good not great not a master and
certainly not a legend so I I had to
change my mind I have to be the best at
least I want to be the best or I
couldn't survive in the fighting game
community then I I completely change my
mind I stopped praying any other
fighting game then I stick to pray only
one game Street Fighter 4 to kill threw
himself into his new life and other
fighting games faded away I
change a lot even in my yes lifestyle
yes a lot of things not just in in the
game and my name is you know Hajime
Hajime is one yes my grandfather's made
me become number one Street Fighter was
everything now and he would give his
life to it in a way that no other player
could match f-80c floyd for the fireball
Stalin is Tokyo right now topitos Ultra
Street Fighter 4 career was about
consistency for over a year he only
missed top eight seven times winds were
still infrequent but he was grinding
facing every tournament with a new sense
of purpose and through it all he still
found the time to be the over-the-top
personality the fans fell in love with I
know every corner man he gets second
phrase and I know Larry you want to be
champion I'm for takedo pushed and
pushed beating some of the game's top
talent and even made top eight at Evo in
2015 the first time since his heart
breaking 2nd place finish in 2013
just a series of unfortunate events
therefore Caggiano foe and lucky for
Tokyo that he didn't press a button
right there at the end it seemed like he
might have taquito couldn't make it past
momochi and gamer B but when those two
went on to play in the tournament grand
finals Tokyo remained the honorable
competitor when momochi stick broke mid
set it was the murderface who offered up
his equipment to get the tournament back
on track the steepest mountain taken
down once again the tournament point
from momochi he has to win these two
rounds oh no no no James no James not
like this not like this Tokyo finally
broke through at Canada Cup 2015 the
grueling 10 game grand final set against
Fudo has gone down in history as one of
the greatest Street Fighter 4 sets of
all time what is it
so light so light and he backed off and
then he still got like oh eight seconds
all we got super Tokyo forgot he had it
okay I like that runs loot over there Oh
long enough no Rumple out of it these
two players are pulling out every trick
every move that these characters have
Fudo fighting all the way rain how they
run out of gas although it is he did the
work of reversal the pull up that meanie
focus focus I've been doing so much
working again kudos saves that wake up
teepee in the situation for the last
game and go get a stay away he didn't
want to stay away he wanted to go in
here good enough
here comes fruit oh he's gonna get a ton
of damage off of this he's gonna get a
tongue up down the top of it here we go
down when he come in what's the mix of
powder and he wanted it but Sookie don't
block trying to push Oh between these
two competitors as you can see the
relief on Sookie toes face you can see
how much heart that he put into this
massless turnin here but that momentum
didn't carry through to Capcom Cup which
opido the launch of Street Fighter 5
marked a turning point for competitive
fighting games the game was built from
the ground up with eSports in mind with
a pro - were ready to go day one which
meant toe Kido wasted no time getting to
work the murder face spent the entire
first half of the year in top three but
there was always one player just ahead
of him the Capcom Cup Tokyo met
infiltration in a string of grand finals
and only managed to topple him once but
when he did it was magical oh he's got
the head this kinda stuff is
Oh Peter what's it this is gonna be
enough to kill he can't kill maybe not
quite Tokyo and it doesn't it doesn't
people might be kept up with a perfect
Tokyo has done it he has done it he's
qualified here at CEO with a perfect and
you can see the elation on his face but
fortunately for taquito that early
momentum all but petered out by Capcom
cub so Kido China build up that meter
for the critical art uh no actually he
spends what of it any mister cut
overhead one more he got it oh boy but
he didn't go all the way in all right
there's a huge opportunity looking at
AIDS a beside himself he has taken it
victory had escaped him once again
Tokita played all of Street Fighter 5
season 1 with Ryu but Akuma season 2
launch was the beginning of a new age
the era of takedo it was interesting
when Akuma came out I think everybody
was a little like we're not sure how
good the character has been a good bad
like where he is until this and in Tokyo
he like famously told his manager he's
like trust Tokyo after proving that
Akuma was far from the weak character
some thought he would be Takeda was
signed by echo fox alongside a who's who
of fighting game free agents that's it
again two for two on the demons is that
it here that you YouTube monsters get
ready to get to Tokyo BAM nine demon
compilation while Tokyo was establishing
himself as the Akuma player to watch
there was a new contender for best in
the world
Punk and up-and-coming North American
player was blowing through tournaments
and quickly became a favorite to win the
biggest tournament of the Year Evo
Punky's by the best player I are the
very surprised if he was not in top
eight all signs pointed to Punk becoming
the first na Street Fighter champion in
more than a decade and after he defeated
Tokyo early in the tournament his
ascendance seemed all but certain that's
it he should be able to confirm into the
critical art
book is gonna take it over tokino and
advance over onto the winter side top 8
but taquito bounced back because of it
Tokyo is gonna take it over key dough
what a run from this guy the only men to
beat him all weekend is waiting in that
Grand Finals of evolution he found
himself staring down Punk'd in the grand
finals he just ate the Thai kick and the
beautiful side switch there from Tokyo
there he has the opportunity to go
either direction is that Oh could it be
a stunning very close he hit up but
he's so genius the time he's in a talk
about a bunk a grand finals of evil he
finds a hit fungus for sure Ted landed
into it he's been shot the Beavers let
us save himself
chip becomes a concern if he can get
another like true small hit Tokyo Tokyo
has any trigger oh here he comes
except throat a keno has set up to the
Luthor's back and essentially this
useful kiddo the momentum is massive
looking miserable here for causing so
much trouble is so this is
is where the mental attitude comes into
play I've never seen a moon like this
he's just not prepared
he's unsettled by Tokyo if the nerves
are getting to him the stakes here at
evolution that confirm again the back
throw he is marching all over of Tokyo
in this game is his they'll be amazing
positioning you know he's gonna have to
set up here left or right you got again
oh my god is that enough he is dead
okie-doke gets another round
he's got the trigger he finds a hand
he'll kill
[Applause]
even now it's difficult to explain just
how badly toki doe defeated pond
he took the ascendant rookie and brought
him back down to first
he took his competitive spirit and beat
it into the ground crushing him in front
of the biggest crowd fighting games has
to offer but instead of gloating tokyo
finished the tournament with a message
of love for the fgc the community that
had brought him all this way that
inspired the change in his life that
carried him to victory congratulations
you know you came all the way from Japan
is there anybody at home or is there
anybody that you want to give a shout
out to that's one thing I want to say
hiking game it's something so great it's
a difficult in a word at the time I have
a long story because I I lost
a lot I lost two Daigo I lost the
hamachi and then I stuck long time I
changed my style but to at first it's
doesn't didn't work with over little I
improve myself if I do good effort the
team
control
yes that I want to say that that's why I
say a fighting game it's great
taquitos definition of being the best is
very different from most people's it'll
mean how to avoid it in a bottle they're
gonna do it by you so I'll still get
just 101 of what was already mother's in
there we'd skip tonight well hold an
orthography no homo Solomon would I know
no cannot be in the law
aqua nice tie that's why Tokyo
challenged I go to a first to ten as
part of die goes from oh no michi show
matches series he basically went to die
go score he was like he isn't known to
be the best in the long sense again it's
really good opponents so for me to be
better than him I needed to win
championships I need to study hard I
need to be like a face of the community
and I need to be better than him at like
what he's the best right and more
importantly a win would allow him to
finally call himself the best in the
world like Tokyo did to Punk
Daigo crushed Tokyo spirit
[Applause]
[Music]
taquito didn't shrug off the
soul-crushing loss he learned from it
and used it to fuel his competitive
spirit
[Applause]
Pepito appeared in 11 grand finals
during the 2018 season and won six of
them he amassed more CPT points in one
season than anyone ever has and through
it all he's kept on grinding go through
the B reversal knocks him down
[Applause]
[Music]
Tokita wasn't beside himself when he
lost two men rd or even when he came
second to problem x at evo 2018 because
toki doe demands perfection and when his
opponents come at him perfectly
he will never be upset if he is evil I
lost to him but how to say I didn't
upset it so much
oh you are good you are better and here
congratulation just I might my feeling
with your conversation he will just a
man more from himself
many would say the taquito is already a
legend he's shown mastery in dozens of
games and absolutely dominated Street
Fighter 5 he's played fighting games
longer than most of his opponents have
been alive and shows no signs of
stopping anytime soon but he still isn't
satisfied would beating Daigo making the
best would winning Evo Capcom Cup and
everything else make him the best toki
doe doesn't think so
victory alone won't cement his legacy
takedo wants more I want to be the
president
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]